what's up  what's up  what are you talking about  oh you don't want to play with snacky  anymore  i don't play with snacking anymore  you just want to tear look what she did  i just bought that like a few months ago  and she's already like torn into [ __ ]  oh well  pokey she's like i don't care i do what  i want  i do what i want i'm gonna tear up this  side too she also tore up the other side  yeah  i do what i want says pookie  i do what i want  yeah  oh she's doing it she's doing it  yeah  make those treats come out  make those treats come out  are they coming out did you get one  yeah she got one  you got one  snacky gave up the goods  i got her that for christmas last year  it's from temptations it's called snacky  the snowman  you put treats inside  and she like knocks the [ __ ] out of that  thing yeah  he loves snacky don't you snoopy snacky  and pokey they're best buds